Traduttore: Claudia Cesetti
Revisore: Luca Di Cola
Grazie, comincio con una confessione:
mi sono visto come primo dei relatori
sulla lista,
sulla rete,
pensavo di introdurre la problematica
e portare l'attenzione sul territorio.
Beh, un territorio profondamente mitico
alla base, diciamo, del mio pensiero c'è:
come persarlo questo territorio?
Allora riporto l'attenzione sul territorio
dopo queste conferenze molto belle,
molto brillanti, molto promettenti anche
di un futuro affascinante.
Però, il futuro di questa zona mitica
è ben rappresentato
dalla condizione di Sisifo.
Vi ricordate Sisifo?
Sì
Lui ha detto: Re-start.
Sisifo è certamente,
di tutti i personaggio mitici
della Gracia antica,
quello che incarna il 'Re-start'.
Perché?
Doveva sempre ricominciare,
facciamo vedere l'immagine.
Qua...
vi ringrazio
doveva sempre portare la roccia
e ricostruire in un certo modo.
Era considerato l'uomo più intelligente
della Grecia contemporanea.
Era come Prometeo
dedicato alla protezione della gente,
dell'unità.
Evidentemente per questo,
faceva arrabbiare Zeus.
Perché lui, invece, era sempre
contro l'umanità.
Ha voluto e ha potuto per un momento
incatenare la morte,
vuol dire che la morte è sparita
per un po' di tempo
dalla cultura.
Però questo ha fatto sì
che venisse condannato.
Io penso che una zona di terremoto,
la dimensione mitica che ne corrisponde,
che 'Restart' deve far parte della cultura
e lo è per caso
lo è, però, non è assimilato
in questo.
Quando sei...
in un paese come l'italia
che è il più sismico dell'Europa.
Devi pensare che
siamo in una situazione molto particolare,
che circonda il monte Vettore
che è chiamato,
voi lo sapete certamente tutti,
il cratere sismico.
Questo cratere mette insieme 4 regioni
importanti e bellissime dell'Italia
e ciascuna ha una proporzione
del pericolo,
ciascuna è toccata alla sua estremità
dalla sensazione di pericolo.
È per questo che concludo questa slide
dicendo: abbiamo una cultura del sisma.
Per esempio, vedendo questa immagine,
sono due mesi dopo il 24 agosto,
la più grande scossa,
seguita nel 26 da una seconda scossa
meno forte
e ancora un'altra il 30 ottobre.
E questo dice molto sulla molteplicità
straordinaria delle scosse
della dimensione sismica.
Non si sa e non si pensa
fondamentalmente...
che quando siamo sulla terra
serve una forte scossa per sentirla
quando si è verificata quella del
24 di agosto,
ero nel letto a Roma,
e la casa tremava abbastanza.
Mi è successo due o tre volte
di essere in zone del genere
e allora nessuno si preoccupa
quando è solo questo, evidentemente.
Però la cosa che ho scoperto in Sant Jose
al Museo di Saint Jose in California,
che facevano simulazioni e facevano vedere
in tempo reale le scosse,
si vedeva una cosa del genere:
una quantità fenomenale
di piccoli pezzettini
Io, diciamo, mi occupo molto delle
nuove tecnologie
vuol dire che...
i Big Data sono una cosa che
vengono in mente quando tu pensi a
studiare con dettaglio infinito
ciascuna di queste piccole scosse
per arrivare a prevedere
la prossima scossa.
Non so fino a che punto
i Centri di Ricerca sul Terremoto
lo fanno adesso e fino a che punto sono
già arrivati.
Ho fatto ricerche ma non ho trovato niente
sul momento.
Ma mi sono detto,
il problema non è là.
Il problema, il caos più grande,
non sono le macerie.
Il problema è lì,
il problema è la rottura dell'anima umana
che crea per alcuni questa situazione.
Vedete 308
o 9 non so se sono 8 o 9,
casse per i morti, feriti dell'Aquila.
"Ormai l'Aquila si è aperta"
dice Ermano Lisi l'assessore comunale
all'architetto Pio Ciccone.
Entrambi archiviati,
"Tu ancora non te ne stai rendendo conto
ma l'Aquila, sì è aperta, ma
le possibilità saranno miliardi.
Io sto cercando di prendere 160 case,
se non le prendi adesso non le prendi più.
Questo è l'ultimo passaggio di vita dopo
Sibota. Hai finito e le prendi ora."
"O le prendi ora o non le prendi più."
risponde Ciccone,
"Esatto" continua.
Faccio sempre finta di parlare come loro,
evidentemente no.
La grande frase è quella
"Esatto" continua Lisi
"Abbiamo avuto il culo di..."
"del terremoto" interviene Ciccone
e Lisi conferma
"il culo che in questo frangente
con tutte ste opere che ci stanno
tu ci stai pure in mezzo
o non ci sta".
Immaginiamo che questo è solo un momento
tragicissimo, orrendo nella storia,
ma non lo è
n-o-n l-o è.
C'è un grande problema nella zona
che non è così solidale,
tranne nel momento in cui
è appena successa la cosa.
C'è questa corruzione feroce all'Aquila
un disordine burocratico, assolutamente...
Manuel Orazi ha scritto un libro...
un articolo importante su questo.
Lui dice che per tutto
un clima di sfiducia
generalizzata e trasversale ha reso
la ricostruzione un nodo gordiano.
Solo iniziative portate avanti
da soggetti privati
sono andate a buon fine, rapidamente:
buona notizia!
Conseguenze: una mancanza
di visione d'insieme del territorio
quello che voglio con le mie idee
portare avanti
e rottura del tessuto sociale.
E allora perché si avverte
una maggiore necessità di etica
nell'ambiente sismico?
Una zona dove la gente deve sentire
letteralmente la sua posizione
dentro questo ambiente.
Incertezza, insicurezza, precarietà
e caos politico,
perdita della fiducia nelle istituzioni,
sentimento diffuso di disagio
ed, infatti, è strano come per la gente...
io ho vissuto per 8 anni, in una zona
veramente pericolosa del Canada
che si chiama "Port Hope":
"Il porto della speranza"
dove c'era la più grande "usina"
o fabbrica
di raffinamento di Uranio.
Raffinare l'uranio vuol dire
portare rifiuti
e questi rifiuti sono capaci di farti male
molto male.
infatti, la quantità di cancro
che era successa in Port Hope
era enormemente, ma chiaramente
più elevata di altri villaggi
con le stesse condizioni
poi c'è l'ascensione generale
di solidarietà fisica,
però,
io ho visto un po' su Tolentino
a Tolentino si fa un Re-start.
Si è fatto un Re-start,
Da un'iniziativa locale,
che ne parlava benissimo Orazi
l'Ungheria al soccorso
della chiesa dei Sacconi,
è un bel segno, una bella cosa.
L'Ungheria non è stata così gentile
per i migranti, lo sappiamo,
ma almeno ha fatto un po' di sforzo
per Tolentino.
L'idea..
ci sono molte di questo tipo di cose
nel mondo per aiutare
però, "Run for Tolentino"
non era una cosa da negligere.
Poi, c'è questo posto
meraviglioso
veramente bello, devo dire
Michele De Lucchi
e questa iniziativa di TEDx Macerata
di portarlo qua
piuttosto che farlo a Macerata
che non è stata un'idea sbagliata.
Allora il problema è questo.
La soluzione forse è questa
ogni anno...
ma non ho trovato quello dell'anno scorso.
c'è il Sole 24 che fa il paragone
secondo criteri assolutamente precisi
sulla dimensione smart,
vuol dire attrezzata.
Non è il caso nella zona
questa zona non è molto attrezzata
E la dimensione benessere
Città smart o città felice?
La cosa interessante è che
si vede qua
l'Aquila,
né felice né attrezzata,
e questo si capisce.
Però si vede qua:
Ascoli Piceno e Macerata.
Okay, non sono Smart
sì, un po' smart lo siete.
Però hanno una certa felicità
vuol dire che vivere nella zona mitica
nella quale siamo,
non implica normalmente
perdere il senso della vita;
che è molto fortemente
il racconto di Albert Camus
nel mito di Sisifo.
Chi ha letto "il mito di Sisifo"
di Albert Camus?
è un'opera importante di una cultura
straniera, è francese. Però...
andate a vederla, è
veramente una cosa che vi da un po' di...
Termina...
il testo di Camus si chiude
su questa frase:
"Sisifo, guardando la roccia
della montagna,
ritrovando un momento di respiro
e non fa più lo sforzo di portarla
ritrova...
(sapendo perfettamente che dovrà rifarlo)
ritrova questo momento dove può pensare
che è felice."
Che è una cosa superba
magnifica, nel senso di
un messaggio sociale.
(Risata)
Come, allora, creare una cultura
della solidarietà?
La prima cosa è una collaborazione
interregionale.
Una collaborazione che va oltre
la regione propria
dove c'è tutta la divisione delle risorse
che vengono a ciascuna regione
dopo un terremoto
dovrebbe essere considerato, comunque,
come un capitale comune
in un certo modo
e dovrebbero essere...
Lo so che politicamente
non è una cosa da dire
specialmente della gente del posto.
Ma, siccome si tratta di una situazione
molto particolare dell'Italia
questa zona intorno al cratere,
perché non farne una regione,
una nuova regione?
Che prende queste zone più,
diciamo, minacciate.
Condividere, evidentemente,
una visione d'insieme
intorno alla sfida comune.
Praticare l'intelligenza collettiva;
mi sono molto occupato
dell'incelligenza colletiva
per insegnare ai miei studenti
a non considerarci come,
isolati nel sistema,
ma come, lavorando insieme,
arrivare a produrre cose importanti
da imparare per loro e da produrre
nella loro vita.
Adesso insegno nella scuola di Design
del Politecnico
i miei studenti lavorano in piccoli gruppi
e ciascuno ha la propria responsabilità.
Ritrovare la felicità urbana.
Mi sono molto occupato di questa
problematica:
come rendere una zona totalmente ferita
come ad esempio, Torre Annunziata,
nella baia di Napoli.
Una città che è stata al più alto livello
di importanza e di lusso
che adesso è andato completamente
sprecato.
Come creare lì un sentimento
di appartenenza
e di orgoglio di appartenenza,
ho usato questo metodo.
E concludo un po' su che vi abbiamo fatto,
questo è a Fiuggi.
Vedete, tutte le scuole di Fiuggi
si sono messe insieme
per creare con ciascuno degli studenti un
tassello che rappresenta il loro lavoro.
Questo tassello va a creare
un'opera comune,
un'opera d'arte, comune.
La differenza è che,
non è una cosa anonima
ciascuno dei tasselli ha
un rapporto con la rete
o con un telefonino, con un dualcode
con tutte le tecnologie
che si possono immaginare.
Ciascuno dei tasselli racconta la storia
della strada dentro la quale
vive il ragazzo
e per raccontare questa storia, usa
i transmedia, vuol dire
usare il suo telefonino, la videocamera,
usare tutte le cose a disposizione,
fa interviste, prende le fotografie
delle famiglie che hanno vissuto
con le quali ha potuto fare un intervento
o un'intervista
e creano un dossier ciascuno
su questa strada.
La mia proposta per la zona,
lasciate perdere
la creazione interregionale
penso che, non succederà mai.
Però la mia proposta intanto è
di immaginare una collaborazione
interscolare
cominciamo con i ragazzi
perché i vecchi, beh, sono ancora capaci
anche di...
ma il futuro è nelle mani di questi.
Creiamo una collaborazione,
una rete interscolare
dentro la quale gli studenti creano
o un'opera comune per la zona,
o una comune per tutte e quattro
le regioni
rimesso in diversi posti,
tutto questo si deve pensare.
Ma ciascuno racconta il disastro,
la ricostruzione
diciamo, il suo punto di vista su ciò
che è successo.
Un'opera, diciamo, un monumento connesso
non solo per quelli che vengono
a visitare la zona e che possono usare
il telefonino per vedere la storia
individuale di ciascuna delle case,
ma anche la possibilità
di condividere questo mondialmente
e così attirare anche fuori,
come già è successo
attirare fuori del paese, della zona
aiuto, incoraggiamenti, partecipazione
ed è fondamentale creare un sentimento
di appartenenza e di riconoscimento
che questa zona è veramente molto
più larga della città
che è stata ferita subito,
senza sminuire per niente
per niente diminuire il valore
e l'importanza di ciascuno dei disastri.
Il fatto è che non possiamo pensare
che non succederanno più,
e lo sappiamo perfettamente,
ma invece di fare un po' come le guerre
dell'infanzia:
tu corri, tu corri, tu corri,
ma io non sarò toccato
se pensi che tu non puoi essere toccato
non lo farai più.
No, il fatto è che...
l'idea è di: toccato o non toccato
ferito o non ferito,
di condividere
il sentimento di appartenenza a questa
grande opera,
di sostenere la problematica
del terremoto.
È un po' quello che volevo
condividere con voi.
Grazie
(Applausi)